à quoi ça sert un honnête mais en fait
on peut se poser la question
il ya beaucoup de scientifiques
aujourd'hui qui dise lui-même se
comporte comme un parasite pour la
biosphère pas ce qui détruit tout et
n'amène rien et la terre a perdu la
moitié de ces espèces animales en 40 ans
l'extinction s'accélère disent les
experts et vous savez je crois que nous
recevons une sorte d'ultimatum de la
nature
[Musique]
si on ramenait l'histoire de la terre ça
vienne est apparu sur la planète plus à
23h59 56e mais ça veut dire qu'on a
quatre semaines d'existence et 1,4 ce
grand on a réussi à massacrer latin de
façon extraordinaire et un virus le sa
covedette gérance il dessinera pas
l'humanité
il n'a pas intérêt à exterminer son
absence elle est suicidaire de tomber
dans cette radicalité mais lui mais
regardez la quantité d'espèces que nous
avons fait disparaître de la surface de
la terre
définitivement et les autres qui sont
sur le respirateur artificiel
on a le droit d'exister on a le droit
aussi de se développer mais de façon
durable avec la biosphère et en harmonie
avec le reste de la création tout ça la
place de l'homme dans la biosphère il
faut interroger l'enfant la chose à
faire pour moins que toutes ces drames
convient aujourd'hui on y sus à faire un
petit peu de positif avec ça ou lui et
nous on a manqué le virage assez de
vouloir copier la stratégie vise à
protéger la compétition n'aurait pas
séduit autant de place dans notre
imaginaire situe l'imaginaire occidental
mais chacun pour soi puis la vie c'est
une chaîne alimentaire chacun my celui
qui le précède et devient la nourriture
de celui qui le suit et à la fin il
restera les grands traits paiera ses
impôts ça le capitalisme et dans ses
dérives mais les plans les plans sont
remisées depuis le début sur la
collaboration
le partage et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
soient qui ont proliféré autant les
planches collabore avec les insectes
pollinisateurs ou leur production quand
on descend dans le sol les racines ce
sont des mosaïques tout ça il collabore
à des champignons les mycorhizes qui
naissait à absorber les nutriments du
sol et nico ries collabore avec les
bactéries 20% des produits de la
photosynthèse il faut acheminer dans la
terre pour remercier les champignons et
remercie les abeilles les pollinisateurs
alors d'honneur du nectar et collaborer
avec les mammifères les tanks ont
inventé aussi les fruits fruits ça sert
à rien une graine louis la balle fuse
mais le flux autour c'est juste un
leurre pour dire aux mammifères
tiens je te remercie de transporter ma
crème plus loin de faire préférer ma
maman mon espèce c'est ça je pense qu'il
faut à revenir au modèle des plantes la
planète leur appartient et peut-être que
le modèle à copier celui des végétaux
[Applaudissements]
le mépris qu'on a pour les places on le
retrouve dans cette expression là ils
végètent cette prime soit faire c'est un
légume on le dit souvent mais les
craintes sont tellement plus puissants
que nous la preuve si toi moi on est là
en train de jaser en amérique du nord
c'est parce que ar 15 34 ans gars qui
s'appelle jacques cartier qui est partie
de l'europe qui est venu ici il
cherchait quoique arctique il chercher
quoi christophe colomb kicherchekoi jean
tabou qui cherchait des graines de
plantes l'histoire de l'humanité cette
histoire des décors c'est l'histoire des
graines c'est une histoire de grand fayt
bois tu gardes de la salade voilà